Here's how I get the very most out of my Olaplex.
This is for the number three,
and this is something that a hairdresser told me not that long ago.
Game changer. I start with slightly damp hair.
I washed it with shampoo, but I did not use any conditioner.
Section it a little bit. For the bottom parts,
I'm not gonna use very much,
like, literally that much.
Then for these sections up here,
I use a little bit more that much.
Pretty saturated in the Olaplex.
I'm going to take a butterfly clip,
we're gonna clip it up,
and I'm gonna use one of these plastic hair caps
to really keep the moisture in there.
So cute. Then I like to just put a scarf over all of it.
I will go clean the house,
homeschool the kids, laundry,
get started on dinner. I will just let this sit several hours.
The bottle says to let it sit for 10 minutes.
I honestly think they're just trying to get you to buy more bottles,
because it continues to work long after 10 minutes.
As long as your hair is a little bit wet,
it'll continue to work. At least that's what my hairdresser told me.
So that's what I've been doing,
and I love it. I've used this stuff for years,
and this is hands down the best way to get the most bang for your bug.